president trunk threatening bold new
action in the fight over border security
Trump saying he'll shut down the
southern border amid new warnings about
a wave of immigrants overwhelming the
system the president already cutting
foreign aid to three Central American
countries Guatemala Honduras and El
Salvador this weekend
this comes as Border Patrol agents
expect to see over a hundred thousand
apprehensions in March alone that's the
highest in over a decade and the Customs
and Border Patrol commissioners saying
the situation is at a breaking point and
that he's quote never seen anything like
this before
homeland security secretary Kirsten
Nielsen announcing she is ordering
hundreds of additional agents to the
border to deal with the problem
this latest potential move by President
Trump is igniting fierce debate from
both sides it certainly isn't a bluff
you can take the president seriously and
this president is looking at the metrics
when the president says he's going to
close the border that is a totally
unrealistic boast on his part the
Democrats will not give us any
additional money to do this they won't
give us any additional people and
importantly they will not change the law
that is acting as this giant magnet for
people from South and Central America to
come into this country well we're gonna
do everything we can to stop it it's
totally absurd what are we supposed to
do you have the Mexican government
allowing thousands of people to walk all
across Mexico they provide them buses
they drop them off at the border and
they say here United States still with
this problem Pete we got a very serious
problem you have the Secretary of
Homeland Security saying I can't
guarantee that I can protect the country
I can't guarantee who's coming in I you
have now those Border Patrol guys saying
they've never seen anything like it
they're completely overwhelmed it's like
a cry for help in Washington is actually
where the problem could be solved but
they're throwing up their hands let the
throwing up their hands including former
Obama administration officials like jeh
Johnson coming out this weekend saying
it is a crisis it's 1,000 a day when I
was the DHS secretary would have been a
bad day yep now we've got 4,000 a day to
not call it a crisis is to just totally
do that
Sanders though did call it a crisis this
weekend but they call it a different
kind of a crisis in a certain sense they
don't see it as a law-and-order crisis
they don't see it as a reflection of the
fact that this president has been
serious about this problem and Congress
never has been and why do we keep trying
to do things that don't
work on this on the questions of aid to
Guatemala El Salvador and Honduras you
have leaders of those countries that are
helping to facilitate their citizens to
leave those countries through Mexico to
our country yet we spent hundreds of
millions of dollars billions over years
trying to fix their governmental
structures and their economy so that we
don't have this problem at what point do
you say this aid isn't working so we're
gonna curtail it because it's it's not
helping us improve our center right and
our supportive of the United States and
I don't know do how do you feel about
cutting off the aid you think that will
actually help us or backfire backfire
tremendously look at the percentage the
where the money goes Dana it's like 40%
of the money goes to economic aid to try
to stabilize and help those economies
grow so people can have jobs there more
than half of the money goes to either
law enforcement or crime suppression in
other words dealing with gangs in the
light so again that makes people feel
safer they're less violence they're less
likely to decide that it's worth their
time to enter into again and you know
Dana's here she's made this point on the
show repeatedly we need to invest in
those countries substantially as a first
step to stop people from making that
trip but I would say this I don't think
closing the border is going to help us
if the problem is the humanitarian
crisis I think that more people will
come to the border if they say oh that
borders being closed the border is
closed and then you're gonna have to
detain more people and we know the big
problem here this is what people are
talking about Pete is that we don't have
the facilities or the staff to deal with
this if the Democrats you don't want to
planetary they do want to fund it but
they don't want to play what has been
Donald Trump's cruel politics of family
separation that's Dana what I think
President Trump is doing right now is
trying to put as much pressure on
Congress to actually do something
because there are easy solutions to try
to solve this problem with this influx
of Central Americans seeking asylum in
the country you can do things like the
florist degree you can close loopholes
like a loophole in the 2008 anti human
trafficking law that changes the way
differentiates the way you treat Central
American unaccompanied minors versus
those coming from Mexico there's things
that Congress can do or
ghetto asylum and look at the disconnect
between the amount of people that pass
that initial screening but just a really
small amount like nine percent that
actually get granted asylum in the
courts but instead Congress has been
making the problem worse and we see that
with the conferee solution that came for
DHS funding and essentially what they
did is you had Democrats trying to
reduce the amount of ice detention bills
you had them tying the hands of
President Trump in both funding for a
wall in the way that he could build the
wall and then even things like section 2
to 4 which essentially gives deportation
immunity to potential sponsors with
unaccompanied minors so instead of
helping the situation Congress has made
it worse
well that's that is sometimes the
shutting down on the border that's a
that's a financially that's dangerous
for us but yeah there's a crisis within
a crisis and we don't have enough Border
Patrol agents to cover this so what
we're doing is is we're taking them away
from our sea and airports to where we
protect around to go to this situation
was leaving us vulnerable and looking I
was doing some investigating and the
hiring process is broken to get these
Border Patrol agents out there 9 out of
10 applicants fail the polygraph which
means it's really like if they make
especially with our veterans veterans a
lot of times I turned away because one
of the questions like have you ever
killed anyone and someone in combat has
a combat kill they're automatically
disqualified so getting right that's
according to my source yes that's and
that's that's wild to me for the people
that are there is really love they're
exhausted and there's even there's some
rumors that the last time during the big
during the shutdown they have been paid
yet the back hours so there's a lot of
things going on a crisis within the
crisis then on top of that you know
Congress has to do a lot of things one
they've got to fix those visa loopholes
because most of our legal immigrants are
coming over legally they're just not
going back so that's another big issue
so there's a lot of things going on on
top of all of that speaking of crisis
why we're dealing with all the stuff on
our borders let's not forget our farmers
let's not forget those floods like we
have a lot of crises right now that we
don't need arguing in politics and many
decisions yes we
you know just going back to where you
started tires which was economically
what an impact this is going to have on
Commerce our third largest trading
partner Indians Mexico this is on the
Mara knows whose jobs are being taken
away through we guess what P driven it's
got it American it's gonna hurt American
jobs because Peary will be put out of
work in terms of skyrocketing prices on
cars alcohol produce people are saying
in three weeks we're not going to have
this is I think this is the frustration
of President Trump because ever we
people are acknowledging now that there
actually is a crisis on the southern
border jeh Johnson who is that sorry do
you mind if I do that we have the sound
from former DHS secretary jeh Johnson by
anyone's definition by any measure right
now we have a crisis at our southern
border according to the Commissioner of
CBP there were 4,000 apprehensions in
one day alone this past week and were on
pace for 100,000 apprehensions on our
southern border this month that is by
far a greater number than anything I saw
on my watch in my three years as
Secretary of Homeland Security no I mean
it probably helps to hear from the guy
himself but as he laid out there this is
worse than what he saw when he served
his DHS secretary so I think the fact
that he's entering the fray he's going
on TV is talking about this crisis one
is acknowledgement of the fact that
there really is a lot going on at the
southern border that we need to be
paying attention to and it lends a lot
of credibility because the left and the
media cannot say that this is
manufactured crisis from President Trump
with him weighing in it's not an
invasion it sure is and we mentioned we
mentioned they exploit our laws drug
violence truck payment traffic this is
the really narratives demonizing our
country illegally
one of the best ways to deal with it
would be the ocean fine you're saying
fine well that fines not a name wait a
second these people are most of these
people are families and children
applying for asylum that's when most of
them are illegal children but one of the
things that the Congress could fix this
by the end of the week was the asylum
law piece that that piece of it you can
fix that and then deal with all of these
other things and the descriptions and
everything that actually could help
everybody including those children who
should not be put in that dangerous
position all right the proper move